PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
How do you recover
from an unexpected
subscriber problem?
What happens to the messages?
Stay tuned to find out.
Cat-Out, our asynchronous
order processing service,
is now looking to deploy
an updated subscriber
code, which is great.
But the challenge is
the new executable
may erroneously
acknowledge messages,
leading to message loss.
Best way to deal with this is--
well, you guessed it.
Don't deploy the new code.
Well, is that ever an option?
That's mostly not an option.
So what should they really do?
Well, there is a feature
in Cloud Pub/Sub called
Seek which extends the
subscriber functionality
by allowing you to change
the acknowledgment state
of messages in bulk.
This means you can
replay previously
acknowledged messages.
There are two ways to
perform seek operations.
You can seek to a snapshot
or to a specific time.
If you seek to a
snapshot, it allows
you to capture the
message acknowledgment
state of the subscription.
This means once a
snapshot is created,
it retains all messages
that were unacknowledged
in the source subscription
at the time of the snapshot's
creation and any other
messages published to the topic
after that.
You can replay these
unacknowledged messages
by using a snapshot
to seek to any
of the topic's subscriptions.
Snapshots expire,
and are deleted
if the oldest unacknowledged
message in the snapshot
exceeds the message
retention duration.
So if your subscription
was set to retain messages
for, say, seven days,
but you were a day
behind in processing
the messages,
then the snapshot
of the subscription
would expire after six days.
You can use the same snapshot
for multiple subscriptions,
as long as they
have the same topic.
Seeking to a time marks every
message received by Pub/Sub up
before that time
is acknowledged,
and all the messages
received after that time
as unacknowledged.
But to use the feature,
you have to choose
to retain acknowledged
messages on the subscription.
This can be
convenient, but usually
costs more than snapshots.
It may also be inaccurate,
due to possible clock skews
amongst that Pub/Sub servers.
So if you want to replay
and reprocess previously
acknowledged messages,
just seek to a prior time.
If Cat-Out is deploying
new code for a subscriber,
then should they seek
to a snapshot or time?
Well, they should
seek a snapshot,
because incorporating snapshots
into the deployment process
gives a way to recover
from bugs in the code.
If Cat-Out faced an
unexpected subscriber
problem and no relevant
snapshot is available,
then seeking to past times
is a good way to recover it.
With Cat-Out, we
saw two use cases
where you can use seek feature
in a new code deployment
and in an unexpected
subscriber problem.
Seek to snapshots is also useful
when testing subscriber code
for performance and
consistency, because you
have to use the same
data in every run.
Snapshots enable consistent
data with strong semantics.
That was replaying messages.
What about discarding?
What if Cat-Out wants to
just save on processing time
and cost on backlogged messages
that are no longer relevant?
In situations like that, you can
port or discard those messages.
Just seek to a
time in the future,
and all those messages will
be considered acknowledged.
All right.
So today, we learned how to
replay and purge messages
in Cloud Pub/Sub
using the Seek feature
by seeking to a specific point
in time or to a snapshot.
If you want to try out
the Seek feature yourself,
check out the quick start
linked in the description below.
Join us next time to learn
more about ordering messages
in Cloud Pub/Sub.
Until then, give us
a like, subscribe,
and let us know
what else you want
to learn about Cloud Pub/Sub.